why do you hate Elmo so much he's a
cringing little milk soop of a puppet I
like the Jim Henson puppets they all had
an edge they were funny Jim Henson was
funny he was a terrible Stoner and you
could tell that in Sesame Street I mean
we used to sit around when I was a
teenager and get stoned and watch Sesame
Street I mean oh nobody could invent the
count who hadn't smoked like 8 lbs of
weed dad welcome to my podcast thanks
for the invitation good to see you good
to see you too where are your Uggs
these are my backup slippers man they
look like backup slippers they do yes
they certainly do they're not the
ugliest slippers I have though this is
true okay last week you talked about you
had a story about how much you were
being paid at Harvard and how that was
difficult because Mom was staying at
home and you just weren't being paid
very much MH and I wanted you to tell
everybody about that well when I was a
assistant professor so there are three
tiers of Professor assistant associate
and full and assistant professor is the
beginning position and generally you're
tenured which gives you some job
security at associate and then there are
few more perks that come along with full
Professor um I started as an assistant
professor at Harvard and it wasn't
necessary for Harvard to be particularly
competitive on the celery side of things
despite the fact that they have Untold
billions in their hedge fund Harvard's
really a hedge fund now by the way and
not a university so yes well be careful
what you wish for you know
anyways I wasn't paid enough as an
assistant professor at Harvard to
support a family in Boston and I worked
I'm not complaining about this it was a
great opportunity to be in Boston but
Tammy didn't have a green card so she
couldn't work and we spent no money I
had a like a the most rat box of a car
that you could possibly
Rabe yeah I mean that car the doors
literally fell off that car two weeks
after we sold it to our neighbor now
they the neighbor by the way knew that
the car was in that bad a shape so I
think we traded it to them for partly
because we got their Cadillac anyways we
didn't even buy magazines we we had no
money and uh I had to teach extra
courses so I taught two extra courses
per semester which is a lot because you
you're full loaded especially if you're
doing research is three courses in total
three or four across two semesters so
two per semester I taught twice that
much oh and one day I phoned the dean
and I said well this is I phoned the
dean and I said I don't know what's
going on here but like I can't I'm
having a hard time getting my research
Enterprise up and going because I'm
teaching so much I don't have enough
time to attend to the research and I
don't mind that because I love teaching
but like what the hell how do you Jud
justify this and he said most of our
people consult which was not true many
of the senior faculty consult but to
consult well first of all you have to be
established somewhere for a long time
and you have to have a reputation and
like it takes a long time to build up a
Consulting Enterprise it's not something
you just step into overnight it's like a
decade to build a Consulting operation
it's very hard get patients well well or
not patients but clients clients yeah
yeah right right and uh I wasn't
practicing as a clinical psychologist at
that point although I was licensed
anyways that's when I started the
Enterprises that became exam core um
because I was looking for something I
could capitalize on that I knew about
that would be useful that would be
economically productive you know and
that took off it took a long time like
we didn't really make profit with exam
cor for 15 years and that that's
understand myself and self authoring
yeah yeah so
I just thought it was interesting that
uh I didn't realize that I don't know if
it's still the same now but I didn't
realize that That's how little money
associate professors can make even at
Ivy l oh definitely assistant yeah is it
still the same um I don't know I would L
more expensive now they'd have to be
paid quite a bit more for it to be the
same I would assume right because I
imagine the well the housing market is
certainly more expensive now than it was
I mean Boston's housing market was very
expensive when we were there in the '90s
that had already started although we
did we did buy a house when we were
there in a workingclass town in
Arlington very nice working glass town
and we could afford that just like
barely and we had loans from our parents
for the down payment at least partially
from our parents yeah so I mean it was
fine we just didn't have any money like
the thing is your poverty isn't defined
by your money precisely your poverty is
defined by your opportunity
right and so if you don't have any money
but you have lots of opportunity you're
rich you just don't have any money and
you can have lots of money and be poor I
mean
that's I wouldn't say that's the normal
run of things but it's certainly
possibility partly because money isn't
the solution to many of life's
problems can help it's the solution to
some of them some of them
yeah okay um I have a list of questions
I usually take some from the audience
but there's only one in here from the
audience uh so you talk a lot about
keeping fam together and how two parents
a man and a woman are ideal for a child
minimal they're the minimal necessary
Arrangement so like two wives is
better mean two wives better than a
single mother no I meant two wives and a
husband you said minimal minimal arrang
right right right right a joke yes yes
yes you have to find two wives who would
get along with each other and that's
technically impossible possible hey guys
if you didn't know my dad's going on
tour for his upcoming we who wrestle
with God book if you guys like the
biblical series on YouTube You're Going
to Love This tickets are available at
jordanbpeterson.com and honestly if
there are any of the lectures you guys
should go to it's one on this tour it
could change your life listening to
Dad's lectures brought Mom closer to God
and I think that's what he's hoping to
do for people I'm not sure what other
lecture you can go to that's trying to
deliver that Mom's going to be open for
him and hopefully I can come along to
some of the shows but we'll see how baby
George and my sleep feels about that
tickets are available at
jordanbpeterson.com for shows in the US
starting in February there are also meet
and greet tickets still available I hope
you enjoy this episode um how do you
know when divorce is the right
option well I would say
that's all things considered up to the
adults involved right I don't know if
there is a rule of
thumb that generally what you see and
this used to be encoded in law is
something like IR Inc concil differences
so we've had family members who got
divorced because one of them wanted a
child and the other didn't well possibly
you could negoti negotiate around that
although it's not simple it's a pretty
fundamental difference and so you know
and then I would say repeated actions of
bad faith on the part of one of the
people and that would be repeated
indication that negotiation in good
faith is impossible repeated patterns of
deception that's a really bad one um I
suppose there are probably instances of
profound temperamental
incompatibility I think it's very
difficult for example to take a
relatively
value-free big five dimension if you're
insanely creative and interested in
ideas so high in trade openness and the
person you're with is very much tilted
in the other direction finds no interest
in ideas has very little aesthetic
sensibility that's a very difficult uh
difference to overcome there's no real
negotiation there you know if you're if
one of you is 80th percentile and the
other is 30th percentile that sounds
like a huge difference but it's not
99.9 compared to 0.1 it's not one in a
thousand different you know you're kind
of in the normal range well then you can
there's some room
for
negotiation and expansion on the part
let's say of the less open person and
maybe some appreciation for the norm and
what's more conservative on the part of
the more open person you know because
openness isn't without its downsides
open people can easily be scattered all
over the place and interested in way way
too many things and be diletant and and
be flaky especially if they're not good
at distinguishing good ideas from bad
ideas but if you're really different On
Any Given temperamental Dimension that
makes the corresponding communication
much more challenging like it's very
very hard for someone extremely
extroverted to be with someone extremely
introverted because their whole
orientation to the to the social world
is opposite disagreeable I've seen this
with men and women you'll get a very
agreeable woman who's quite feminine and
a very disagreeable man who's like hyper
masculine and they can't communicate
that happens a lot I wonder if that's
part of the reason this redpilled
community is taken off because a lot of
the people who are figureheads in this
community are extremely disagreeable
like probably first percentile in
disagreeableness and what they teach
other people is men can really be
friends with other men because they
understand each other men can't be
friends with women at all and can't even
really communicate with them that's kind
of what they teach people I wonder if
that's a personality
trait I think that disagree Hy masculine
men have a hard time communicating with
Hyper feminine women definitely but this
is where the gender issue becomes more
complex the radical leftist claim is
that there's a there's no limit to the
number of genders there are and that's
actually true even though they're stupid
well they're stupid they don't know what
they're talking about but there's an
element of it that's true because the
the Cardinal elements of gender
difference in personality are
agreeableness and neuroticism so the
typical hyper feminine woman is
extremely agreeable and high in negative
emotion and the typical man is
disagreeable and low in negative emotion
right so and there's positives and
negatives associated with both that an
agreeable person is very much concerned
with the feelings of other people you
know is concerned with others and you
can see that as a virtue although hyper
agreeable people tend to be resentful
because they don't ever put their own
interests in the they don't put them
forward properly and it's also the case
that there are far more agreeable people
going to therapy to become more
disagreeable then there are disagreeable
people going to therapy to become more
agreeable right so and then with regard
is that because they're disagreeable
though and won't go to therapy or is it
because it's more beneficial to be
disagreeable than it is to be hyper
agreeable well I think that being very
agreeable carries with it that terrible
burden of of continual martyrdom and
self-sacrifice and and I don't think
that if you're trying to make your way
in the world as an individual that
that's there's definite disadvantages to
that a prior position one of the reason
women don't make as much money as men in
comparable positions to the degree that
that's true at all like there's that's
not true if you compare single men and
women in their mid 20s who are childless
in fact the women actually have a bit of
an advantage but but in so far as there
are gender differences in payment for
position one of the contributing factors
is that women are more agreeable and
agreeable women won't go to their boss
and say give me a raise you son of a
[__] or I'll leave and like I can
imagine like men will have a
conversation just like that even if the
guy who's making the claim is the
subordinate you know if if the and
that's a disagreeable mode of
communication it can be overlaid with
humor you know and then with you might
say well what's the advantage of high
trait neuroticism the proclivity to
negative emotion well it's threat
sensitivity and if you're a mother of
infants being threat sensitive is
unbelievably useful because infants are
extremely vulnerable and so you should
be alert to threat you're alert to
snakes well what's the downside well
you're always afraid of snakes that's
the down well yeah well of course of
course but that doesn't mean that it
doesn't have its adapt adaptive utility
but it's still the case that if you have
a disagreeable man who's very
emotionally stable and a hyper agreeable
woman who's emotionally you know who's
who has a pronounced proclivity for
negative emotion it's going to be very
difficult for them to communicate
there's other temperamental differences
between men and women too so if you look
at extroversion men are more so
extroversion is assertiveness and
enthusiasm okay men and women are about
equal in in extroversion but women are
more enthusiastic and men are more
assertive so it breaks there and then in
openness openness breaks down into
interest in ideas and interest in
Aesthetics and women and men are about
equal in openness overall but women are
higher in interest in Aesthetics and men
are higher in interest in ideas you can
see that reflected in the fact for
example that YouTube is primarily a male
domain and that's because it tends to
focus on ideas you know the the the
upper echelons of YouTube let's say so
and men are more this is why men read
non-fiction instead of fiction it's the
same reflection and so you can
imagine a woman and a man who have
virtually no overlapping personality mhm
right now that's going to be relatively
rare because most of the traits overlap
quite a bit but in some you could
imagine that you could categorically
distinguish them while they'd have a
hard time
communicating yeah so this plays nicely
into so so two things one we won't touch
too much on this because we can talk
about this later but we do have an idea
to build a dating app that looks at the
temperamental differences and
personality between men and women and
matches you based on that yeah and a
number of other yeah well the empirical
literature suggests that it's easier to
get along with people who are similar to
you in personality and part of the
reason for that is that part of the way
that you get along with people is by
sharing interests and activities and
what interests and activities you find
compelling are going to be a reflect
reflection of your temperament yeah
we'll look into that too though we could
well with with dad and mom my dad and
mom for example dad's an avid Hunter you
know a dad's relatively disagreeable
which is one of the things you need to
be to be a hunter as it turns out and
mom is very agreeable and she's not
interested in hunting and you had a bit
of that oh my gosh we went gopher
hunting one time it was Julian and I
when we were kids and I don't think I'd
have this issue anymore I wouldn't have
this issue anymore I think this is
partly because I was depressed uh a
large portion actually I think was
because I was depressed but we went
gopher hunting because Gophers destroy
Farmers lands so they actually want you
to come and Hunt gophers and Julian's
shooting gophers like left and right
he's probably seven or something like
that and when you shoot them they scream
they scream this high pitched scream and
I sat in the car with my hands over my
ears so I was probably nine and cried
right right right well when I used to go
hunting with Dad I was too tender-minded
for it too so tenderhearted yeah
tenderhearted yeah yeah but but but but
that's a good example of how
temperamental difference can you know
make make a relation relationship
difficult more difficult because there's
no overlap in a parent there's little
overlap in a parent interest you know
and Tam used to encounter that with her
dad her dad was quite an entrepreneurial
character but he wasn't one of the
world's most aesthetically sensitive
people he had no interest in art
whatsoever right and he just he just
thought it was a practical waste of time
like many conservative people think and
you know she'd haul them along to a
museum and his attitude was what the
hell are we doing in this Museum and why
have we been here for so long right and
that's clear reflection of of different
in difference in interest you know your
M and I are well matched in that regard
because I might be more open than she is
but maybe in some ways likely in some
ways in some ways in some ways yeah yeah
well for a long time I was she is she is
well she's certainly open enough so that
that isn't an impediment in our
relationship and she's very adventurous
MH so you know her and I are quite well
matched in temperament she's probably
more less neurotic than me I would say
maybe maybe I think and probably I think
there's some well we'll have to like
gather data and see but I feel like
there are some personality traits that
can be significantly different and can
still line up like you couldn't put two
neurotic people together no no that
would that's why lesbian relationships
don't last is going to get clipped well
it is why it is why because about 70 75%
of divorces are initiated by women
and the simplest explanation for that is
that on average the most unhappy person
in the relationship is going to be the
woman well why well because on average
she has higher levels of negative
emotion that doesn't necessarily mean
that that negative emotion doesn't
reflect problems in the relationship
yeah but she's going to be more
sensitive to that well so if you put two
women together well you know what do you
think
happens so I mean it's one of the
reasons it's not the only reason the red
pilled Community twists that too saying
like most divorces are initiated by
women so women are the problem which I
don't think no that doesn't that doesn't
follow at all it could be that you know
men are the problem and women just pick
up on it now it's not I mean the right
attitude there is obviously that on
average it's 5050 yeah and and even if
you're thinking about that biologically
it's the only answer that makes sense is
like well men and women they're they
they
co-evolved yeah so there there's no it's
men that are the problem women that
problem that's just ridiculous it's
ridiculous hey guys so last year before
I discovered mold in my house causing
all my issues I had my hormones tested
on the off chance I was having a hormone
issue which I was my hormones were
flattened like all of them they
recovered somewhat after moving out of
that house given I got pregnant a month
after I moved out after not getting
pregnant for a few years um but I wanted
to talk to you about the company I used
to test my hormones merri Health they're
my go-to tellah health company for labs
hormones peptides Physicians that don't
suck they gave me an in-depth look at my
hormones compared to what you'd get at a
regular doctor's office you can sign up
and choose what you want to get tested
or choose some of their panels and they
give you your results broken down and
recommendations for supplements peptides
or treatments that work they're super
easy to work with very straightforward
you get all your information I'm a huge
proponent of monitoring blood work I
think everyone should do it my husband's
now working with them my dad my brother
and me they do work other than hormone
optimization like cognitive enhancement
hair loss prevention body recomposition
the complete package includes the same
elaborate panel I got myself and
actually just redid so we'll see what it
shows now that I'm not living in mold
and with those test results the meric
health clinical team suggests ways to
optimize hormones to get the exact same
panel and medical oversight I got click
the link in the video description or go
to meric
health.com and use code MP to save 10%
at checkout highly recommended pinned in
the description I hope you guys are
enjoying this episode you want to hear
the audience question sure why do you
hate Elmo so
much he's a cringing little milk soop of
a puppet he's whiny he's false he's he's
fake nice there's not he he wasn't a Jim
Henson creation by the way I like the
Jim Henson puppets they all had an edge
they were funny Jim Henson was funny
like he was a terrible Stoner and you
could tell that in Sesame Street I mean
we used to sit around when I was a
teenager and get stoned and watch Sesame
Street I mean oh nobody could invent the
count who hadn't smoked like eight
pounds of weed a Cookie Monster or the
Cookie Monster exactly and so Jim Henson
was a hoot and the Muppet Show was very
funny Elmo's like this Elmo's like the
politically correct puppet of the M
Muppet troops and that whiny voice just
greats everything about that Bloody
puppet greats on me elbow sickening
puppet he's got particularly politically
correct on recent years in Sesame Street
too I saw some clips lately about him
one of his puppet friends decrying
systemic racism for four-year-olds
sickening so no
Elmo's well plus if I remember correctly
there was some unted behavior on the
part of his puppeteer yeah a little yeah
surprise surprise I thought well nobody
could see that coming whose eyes were
open for 20
years okay stupid puppet
advice for people getting he sounds like
that horrible character on Star Wars
that me so oh I know is it the little
bear thing no well there was always an
annoying character like that in every
Star Wars movie for a while um I don't
remember he had eyes out on the side of
his head anyways he's the same character
it's like I'm oh and that they even did
that in Harry Potter with that Bloody oh
Doby do God Dobby and Elmo are the same
creature not Dobby yeah Dobby was
annoying very yeah
yeah advice for people getting over a
breakup well takes some time to like
don't contact the other person well
generally for the psychiatric on the
psychiatric end of things if you're
grieving generally the psychiatric
psychological Community has agreed that
something like a year of grief in a in
consequential to a severe law
is well within the realm of
normative so it's going to hurt
um so don't be too impatient with
yourself I would say what else what else
do you need to
know cynicism and bitterness are not
your
friend um that person isn't reflective
of
women the person you broke up with isn't
reflective of men that's not helpful
right so you don't want to
overgeneralize I don't think you want to
LEAP back in any too soon and you might
spend some real time thinking about not
so much what the other person did wrong
even though there's nothing more
satisfying than that you should spend
some real time thinking about what you
did wrong
especially if this has been a pattern
you know I noticed when I was in college
I broke up with three girls I think in
the space of six months something like
that they were relatively short-term
relationships you know but they they all
ended the same way more or less and I
don't even remember the details but I
thought oh that's not
them that's me and you know it took me a
while to sort out what it was part of it
was that I had a tendency this is very
common in fact I'm sure it's
overwhelmingly the
norm maybe women do this too God only
knows what women do but I had a tendency
to put any woman that I was attracted to
on a pedestal
and that was hard on her and also you
know put me in a demeaned position
immediately which was also not
attractive by the way and so that was an
Ana problem technically and took me a
while to sort that out actually my
perception of women changed when I
sorted it out changed overnight I I saw
one really interesting example of this
so I don't know if I can explain this
properly but maybe I
can if you put the woman that you're
attracted to on a pedestal what you're
really attracted to is your unconscious
idealization of
women and men see their unconscious
idealization of women in someone they're
attracted to especially if the
attraction is pronounced and immediate
right that's a projection
psychoanalytically speaking and then
they confuse the woman with that
idealization which is
very difficult to Bear for the woman
because she's not really there that's
the first problem and second she's going
to get herself in trouble and not know
it because now and then she's going to
do something that violates that ideal
projection and be called to account for
it even though she doesn't know what
rules she's breaking plus the guy won't
be able to listen to her or appreciate
anything about her that's not perfect or
in accordance with that ideal so that
means she can't really talk to him right
she can't reveal anything that's
untoward or that definitely makes sense
M I think that is probably common for
people so so one of the things that
happened when I solved that problem I
was studying a lot of yion psychology at
the time it literally happened overnight
is can remember walking down the streets
of Montreal and I saw an ad on a bus and
you know at that time this was in the
80s they're probably still doing this a
lot of the models that were used by like
makeup companies were very young women
like 14 but made up you know so they
were sexualized it's still the case like
there's very young bottles who were used
you know but but I know that before I
had seen through my own
illusions that I would have seen in the
ad a beautiful woman and then I saw a
girl dressed up like a woman oh that's
interesting wow yeah well there's a loss
in that too like the loss is this is a
loss of maturity is that you know if you
are in love with your ideal then you
have the ideal like you have the
princess
the price you pay is you don't get the
woman now if you want the woman the
price you pay for that is that you have
to let go of the
princess right right now that's what you
should do because the princess thing
isn't going anywhere but it is
definitely a sacrifice it's sort of like
growing up and coming to the realization
that your father doesn't know everything
which of course isn't true in your case
by the way but it's it's there's a loss
in that right like the gain is that you
gain the maturity and the the
self-confidence to go out and make your
own decisions but the loss is that you
had a figure who was an intermediary
between you and the world who knew
everything lots of people who remain
over dependent on their father for
example remain over dependent they're
willing to exist under his thumb even if
it's rather tyrannical because they
don't want to give up the certainty that
there's someone out there in the world
who actually knows what's going on yeah
that's scary of course of course that's
interesting okay so that's what not like
still stick on this red pilled Community
but they're they're interesting I find
it interesting very strange well it's
the beginning of a kind of backlash
against idiot feminism like a widescale
backlash yeah it is it's the opposite in
an also toxic way but that's what these
people are looking for is the princess
and then the problem with the red pill
Community is they're telling all these
young people that the woman they want to
look for is the princess mhm like the
literally a virgin well well well and
part of the problem with that too is
there's a maiden [__] thing that's a
problem there too so there's you could
think of there's two archetypal
representations of women there's more
than two but here's two and they're on
opposite ends and one is the virgin
mother and the other is the you know the
the stripper [__] right and you might
think well if you're going to get
married you want the virgin mother
well
sometimes right well so then and
sometimes maybe the stripper [__] is
the preferable object well now how do
you bring those two together well you
have there has to be a
sacrifice right there's a sacrifice of
Purity certainly and part of the reason
that couples men remain sexually
unsatisfied in their marital
relationships is because you know virgin
mother is for their wife and [__] is
for their stripper
girlfriend well that's not very good for
the stripper girlfriend cuz she ends up
like you know cocaine and back Ellies
that's fun for her it's not so good for
the wife because her idiot husband is
floundering around with [__] and so
that's real fun plus she's like boxed
into her little ice box refrigerator
life having to be picture perfect like a
Stepford Wife all the time yeah right
it's very unsatisfying for everyone
involved this is partly why
Yung what would you say was so insistent
upon integrating The Shadow
it's one of the things you have to do to
have a marriage that's successful is
admit what you want and some of
that's well what was the Freudian stance
the hardest motivational the most
difficult motivational drives to
integrate into a socialized
personality are is sexuality and
aggression well
obviously and that produces a real
challenge but if you can get it right
well it's a huge benefit but it's very
difficult to get right you know and it's
part of the whole how do you how is it
that you maintain respect for a
woman in the light of what would you say
the full range of sexual
activity well that's a hard that's a
very difficult human problem right but
it's manageable it's just it requires a
certain amount of
sophistication so and and it's
hard but it's it's not nearly as hard as
the alternative so
well one of my questions was when when
men and women so separately when they're
looking for someone what qualities for
should they look for and I I
think like one of the mistakes young
people make is people can be insanely
interesting right in all sorts of
different ways and they can have like
you said this kind of mother virgin
personality and then they can have this
like whr personality as well and having
this range makes them interesting
keeping your like getting with somebody
interesting is how you keep this
relationship going so for young men
looking for someone thinking that they
need this ideal person yeah it's to they
need is it's too narrow someone with
range well that's part of maturity is
that well and that's part of subduing
the world so God tells Adam to subdue
the world essentially you know and all
the eco- freaks think that means you
know rape and pillage Mother Earth it
doesn't what it means it means
everything in its proper place
everything properly categorized
it's part of the action of logos and
what you do in a good relationship is
you put everything in its place right so
there's a time for virgin mother and
there's the time there's the time for
you know sexual lenti justness
and everything in its proper place
that's the crucial issue same with
aggression it's not that it's to be
repressed it's that it's to be subdued
it's to be put intellect is the same
thing so Milton characterized Lucifer as
intellect gone wrong and intellect's a
great gift it's a great talent and it is
god-given in that's the simplest way to
think about it in many ways because it's
highly genetically determined highly now
no one likes that it's no wonder because
it's a rather dismal fact of life but so
it's a gift now you might say well how
can the world be a fair place if some
people are given this great gift of
intellect and others aren't and and the
range of people in terms of their
intelligence is it's it's staggering
it's staggering you know like I've
tested people on IQ tests who have iq's
of say 80 which is about where
cognitively impaired
starts from the perspective of the
definition of such things
and you you just can't imagine what if
you're literate you can't imagine what
someone with an IQ of 80 doesn't
know they wouldn't be able to name the
world's oceans that's for sure
they certainly wouldn't be able to if
you gave them a
globe where the continents weren't
distinguished from the water they
wouldn't be able to tell you the
difference between the water and the
continents so and that's
10% it's more than that it's about 10%
of the population and so anyways how do
the cosmic scales balance given that
some people have an IQ of 150 and some
people have an IQ of 70 massive
difference well partly along with
intellect comes pride and the
probability of it going wrong and
there's nothing there's no one more
narcissistic than someone who's smart
and if you are smart that's a real
Temptation it's a real Temptation can
make you bitter as hell the most bitter
people are the smart people who aren't
successful because they feel that
they're yeah they're Shining Light
wasn't given due course and that the
world should fall at their feet and
didn't those are dislikable people oh
unbelievable that's Comic Book Guy on
The Simpsons like they they they nailed
it with him you know he is smart but
that's not enough and you know so the
way the world
works you don't get a gift without a
corresponding Temptation and intellect
is
certainly it has the same characteristic
you can go very spectacularly wrong if
you're smart and it's Pride that does
that so now I don't remember why we were
talking about that in Rel Rel ship to
dating I don't remember why we were
talking about that in relationship to
dating either but maybe it's not
important we were we were we were on the
who to look for but oh yeah we were
talking about range we were talking
about range well one of the things that
happens and I still don't know how we
got into intelligence one of the things
that happens as you mature is
that your personality
variability
increases right so maybe you have a set
point you're extroverted and when you're
a kid if you're extroverted you're
always extroverted you're extroverted at
a funeral but as you mature you're able
to be introverted when the situation
demands it right and everyone can do
that like I had lots of introverts in my
clinical practice who' became very
successful in business and they became
they learned to be extroverted they
still weren't extroverted by
temperament a lot of social activity
still tired them out but they learned
the social skills step by step and so
they were still temperamentally
extroverted but when the situation
required an extroverted response you
know they had it and and one of the
things that you do want in a mate this
is a sign of sophistication is that they
can be the person that the situation
demands that doesn't mean they blow in
the wind right that's not the same thing
as not having character it's adaptive
flexibility in fact one of the
identifying Hallmarks of Personality
pathology so that would be the
personality disorders is that someone
with a personality disorder is the same
person all the time
oh that's creepy yeah yeah you don't
want you don't want people adjusting
their personality and like morphing into
somebody else dependent on who they talk
to because that's lying right but the
ability to read the room yeah wow some
people don't have that yeah well and you
can well and that is a Hallmark of
that's a Hallmark of maturation
because it's a Hallmark of the unfolding
of character even if you put yourself in
new situations constantly new genes turn
on and code for new physiological
structures like it isn't only that you
learn you do learn because you absorb
more information but you also change you
also change physiologically by forcing
yourself enticing yourself into a
multitude of situations you increase
your adaptive flexibility now in terms
of who you look for in a partner it's it
is important my clinical experience
certainly taught me that it's very
difficult to
produce sexual ual interest if that's
lacking right so that's number one well
it has that's like a gift I don't know
if it's number one but I would say it's
it it isn't going to work without it and
it isn't doesn't look to me like it's
something that you can nurture because
maybe you find someone you really like
and they're your best friend and you
wish you were sexually attracted to them
you think maybe that'll come with
time my experience I think I was
agnostic about that because an optimist
would hope that that would be possible
but my experience was watching my
clients try that no it didn't work and
so you need a modicum of
mutual physical interest and maybe more
than a
modicum um intense would be good you
know you the honesty of the person is
yeah that's I don't think there's
anything more important than whether or
not the person you're with is doing
their best to act out and tell you the
truth yeah that's because no long-term
relationship can survive without trust
and trust is dependent on honesty so
that's a that's a major you can get a
long ways with very difficult problems
if you're willing to communicate
genuinely could we test could we put
that into the dating app somehow and
yeah oh that's cool there are honesty
humility Dimensions the hexico
personality model tests honesty humility
and it's probably the opposite of the
dark tetrad great so what happen when
people built personality models is they
got rid of all the evaluative words like
good and evil or even good and bad
anything that looked like a value
judgment and then they discovered a
five-dimensional structure the
five-dimensional structure that
characterizes personality and then
that's been broken down into some
variant like in understand myself we
offer people two subcategories of each
major trait we called them aspects but
the evaluative words actually do index
temperamental variability in fact they
might be the primary index of important
temperamental variability and they were
taken out of the models then they snuck
well because if you kept all the
evaluative words in the models it
collapsed into a single Dimension when
you did the statistical analysis oh I
see okay so everyone who was honest
would answer one well and then the the
other thing is the the uh
the psych the psychologists who built
the personality models wanted them to be
value free and there's some utility in
that because a
scientific a set of scientific
descriptors should in principle be
value-free now whether it's possible to
have a value-free index of human
temperament that's a whole different
question but it's it it's possible in
part like you can see that there's a
normal distribution of agreeableness and
you can't say that it's ethically better
to be agreeable than to be disagreeable
they have positive elements and negative
elements now I think you can say that
it's worse to be a liar than to tell the
truth MH okay so imagine anything that
has that strictly moral Dimension has
been parsed out well the problem with
that is that it decreased the overlap
between personality and
psychopathology because
psychopathological people are often
narcissistic and mellan and Psychopathic
and now you've taken that out of the
descriptive Network so that decreases
the way that you can use personality to
understand
Psychopathology and then it opened up
investigation into personality
Dimensions that weren't captured in the
big five model and that turned out to be
honesty humility that's part of the
hexical model which is Six Dimensions or
I think the opposite of that which is
the dark tetrad interesting proclivities
right and so that would be honest
reliable humble on one end and prideful
narcissistic arrogant mellian on the
other do you think we can get people to
answer questions that show that and they
would
I know how to because I developed tests
that make it impossible for people to
lie great yeah yeah yeah we've used
those to identify
narcissists and people with personality
disorders and they work now that hasn't
been extensively tested
but but and that's a flaw but it's been
tested how much has it been tested
there's no better current alternative
that's how well it's been tested so and
there are ways the other thing you got
to understand too is that if you're
narcissistic you tend to think that it's
a virtue yeah and it's also not that
easy to lie consistently it takes a lot
of effort and you have to be motivated
now it turns out if you tell smart
people that their personality tests are
going to be used to evaluate their
suitability for a job they tilt them in
the direction of conscientiousness and
low neuroticism which is exactly what
they they should do because those are
the best predictors and the it collapses
the five-dimensional structure so people
can fake good and you can imagine that
more intelligent people can fake good
better and so that's a problem when
you're trying to evaluate people using
self-reports for employment suitability
we developed a unfakeable big five that
circumvents that problem it's got some
other prices you have to pay for that
but it does work we paid people to cheat
the unfakeable Big Five I did that work
with Jacob H and they couldn't do it
they could do it a bit but not nearly as
much as they could with the self-re yeah
yeah and then Daniel Higgins and I
worked out some tests that they were
forc Choice tests essentially you have
to admit to one of two bad things and
it's not obvious at all which of them is
worse and if it's only one
comparison then it probably doesn't make
any difference but if I know maybe I
have 20 paired questions I could ask you
and one answer is clearly more
associated with long-term
Psychopathology than the other even
though both are negative and you answer
all the questions in a way that
indicates the worst Choice then I can be
reasonably certain that you know I've
got you right and so that's basically
how we set up the
tests so they're very difficult to fake
I I don't think it's been a long time
since I looked at the tests it isn't
obvious to me that I could fake them if
I came across them now because both of
the choices for example in the force
Choice the other I think one of the
things we did if I remember correctly is
we have five bad
choices and we know which which order
they're in and you have to put them in
order right right and then if you put if
you prioritize the wrong one well that's
costly if you do it repeatedly across a
lot of different questions but yes we
think we can identify the narcissists
and the Psychopaths and the melians and
the and the Liars to be really helpful
on a dating app it might be the most
important thing yes yeah by the way just
so everybody knows too and the women
should really know this those are the
men who engage in short-term mating
strategies the the clinical data on that
are very clear so well sex is just for
fun it's like yes says the
psychopath right and then part of the
reason for that is because that is how
the psychopath operates and that's
clearly there's no dispute about that in
the psychological literature I'm not
making this up that's been well studied
like the we know for example that one of
the things that characterizes children
with a pronounced and relatively
permanent antisocial bent is that they
have sex earlier that's been documented
for decades decades decades yeah what's
a short-term mating strategy well
antisocial behavior is a short-term
strategy it's like I'm going to get
whatever I can from you now and from me
into hell with the consequences it's
like the definition of it's it's like
the definition of criminal
predation so it's this isn't a surprise
it's just a logical consequence of the
behavioral pattern you know what a
criminal does is take advantage now
despite the long term it's the
definition of criminal behavior and so
women should know this it's like if the
guy's all about well you know we're here
for a good time not a long time oh he's
such fun it's like yeah no he's actually
not that much fun and you're you're well
here's another thing we know young women
are much more likely to be fooled by
narcissistic Psychopaths than older
women well why because they're well they
confus well exactly they don't
understand that people can be malevolent
they confuse that malevolence with charm
and you can understand that because like
maybe a woman has a very agreeable guy
that'd be a friend usually and she
doesn't find him that attractive right
and so then she finds someone
disagreeable who's not disagreeable
because he's got Integrity of character
but because he's a psychopath
but a
fing there's a certain confidence
that mimics that that mimics it's not
confidence it's false confidence it's
certainly not competence but you know if
you're competent and secure you don't
care what other people think but that
doesn't mean that if you don't care
about what other people think you're
confident and competent yeah right but
they can easily be confused right very
EAS this is partly why women need to say
no whenever they have the opportunity to
it's a great test and it's also I talked
to Tammy a lot about this I think that's
the primary way that women obtain status
is saying no yeah yeah yeah well imagine
you have women they're being chased by
high quality guys see and they have
enough G to say no yeah it's because
they're above them right that's what's
up with her I'm so Charming how can she
say no to me how dare she say no to me
well stat yeah definitely yeah yeah this
I do believe the fundamental status
marker I I think men believe this I'm
I'm certain of it I mean I remember you
know having conversations with my
teenage friends you know when we're all
enamored of women left right and center
it's certainly the case that the women
who said no they were clearly you know
there were the prudes who said no that's
not the same thing but there were then
there were the women or girls I guess in
this case who were you know attractive
and confident who you kind of you know
and that's men are men any men with
sense are not only looking for that but
immediately attracted by it and if it
puts them off like for the girls who are
listening if a man is put off by the
fact that you say no you should get the
hell away from him as fast as you
possibly can because he doesn't care in
the least for you he doesn't find you
interesting so that's really good for
young people to hear well the other
thing too that women should know is that
if a man sleeps with you and and he
doesn't respect you he the moment he's
finished with you he will have nothing
but contempt for you and girls are often
brokenhearted let's say because they've
slept with some guy and then he doesn't
call them it's like I can tell you that
that guy finished in bed the first thing
he wanted to do was get the hell out of
there as fast as possible because it's
sexual satiation and immediate disgust
contempt and shame immediate
immediate that's not good you don't want
to be the girl on the receiving end of
that there's nothing about that that's
good
no people should hear that yep yeah and
you do I mean I know that I ran into a
lot of people that I now know were
Psychopaths as a young woman for sure
and that's partly I think because I'm
extroverted and so but also because I'm
female and so the extroverts are
attractive and it is the extroverts that
don't really care about anything that
seem confident that are attractive but
if you're a 21-year-old guy
and you're like that the the temptation
of a disagreeable extrovert is to be
narcissistic right so every personality
constellation has its Associated
pathologies so the pathology of
extroversion is
Mania the pathology of disagreeable
narcissism right the pathology of
introversion is depression in
combination with neuroticism so there
isn't an attribute that you get without
a corresponding Temptation while
extroverts are interesting and
enthusiast IC and dominant in social
situations and disagreeable people are
pretty damn good at negotiating on their
own behalf but disagreeable extraverts
can become narcissistic now the problem
is they're
attractive so you know it's a tough it's
a
tough conscientious can help more and
you can get the people that aren't
narcissists that are also disagreeable
and extroverted those people are great
yeah right right the narcissistic ones
yeah well those are sort of like the
tameable monsters the Beauty and the
Beast fantasy
right because the Beast is obviously
disagreeable I mean
obviously
and well and to Rampage around is an
extroverted sort of thing I mean nobody
cares about the Beast who hides in the
back of his
cave so yeah table tameable Beast is a
good it's hard though it's a hard it's a
hard needle to threat and that's you
know the problem that women face let
let's take um a bit of a different
direction given we're at the beginning
of a new year um I thought maybe you had
some kind of tangible advice for people
in making a new year
plan well the most tangible advice what
should they do in order to think about
the next year well the most tangible
advice the most practical thing for
people to do is to do the future
authoring program because it lays out
what to do in great detail and you can
do it badly and quickly and it'll still
help you a lot but so you can go to
self-authoring and do the future
authoring program and it helps you lay
out a vision and people what we do to
adapt to the uncertainty of the future
is we lay a vision on it we lay a vision
on the chaos and we pursue the vision
right and so it's exactly what you do
when you're navigating a boat right you
have a destination in mind and the waves
rise and there's all sorts of
variability but use the destination as
the orienting point like the North Star
and you calibrate your perceptions and
your emotions in relationship to the
goal that's how we navigate and we're
navigating creatures when we say we we
know something we don't mean we can
describe it explicitly that's what we
think we mean when we say we know that
isn't what we mean we mean that we have
a navigation tool we have an accurate
map you need a map and to map accurately
you need a destination and there's no
diff difference between specifying a
destination and developing a vision and
so there's two ways you can develop a
vision roughly speaking you can do it by
the promptings of conscience or you can
do it by the promptings of calling it's
like the interaction between those two
things that's like Divine Providence so
conscience would say to
you here's a bunch of stupid things
you're doing that you could stop doing
that would improve your life now
conscience can be too harsh a master
right so you have to enter into a
dialogue with your conscience and you
may have to enter into a relationship
with it like Pinocchio and
Jiminy because Jiminy is just a [__]
when he starts like he has to learn too
so you have to have a dialogue with your
conscience so that it isn't a tyrant or
or a pushover right but your conscience
can tell you where there are things in
your life that aren't going well and you
can use those as motivation to change i'
like for example when I decided to start
stop drinking when I was 27 or
thereabouts part of the reason for that
there were two reasons one was a calling
reason one was a conscience reason the
conscience reason was I looked at my
life and I thought well when do I do
things I
regret when I'm drinking well do you
want to H have a life characterized by
regret as you start climbing up the
professional ladder and the consequences
become more and more dire and the answer
was well and I established a more
permanent relationship with Tammy and
you know we were thinking about having
kids it's like well do I want that or do
would I rather have a life where wasn't
doing stupid things that I regretted mhm
well and when I quit drinking I I didn't
stop doing everything I regretted but I
stopped doing like 90% of things I
regretted yeah okay so that that and
that's that's very true for people who
drink period most a tremendous amount of
stupidity is alcohol fueled so that was
the conscience end the calling end was I
couldn't write when I was hung over it
was impossible I couldn't make quality I
wasn't operating at Peak efficiency and
maybe that's fine if if you don't care
but I one of the things that really
motivated me and that's continued to
motivate me ever since is I'm very
curious about how much I can do in the
shortest possible period of time that's
fun and so if anything gets in the way
it's like well it's got to go that's
sacrifice that's the sacrifice that
pleases God to dispense with the Lesser
to facilitate movement towards the
greater
well so if you're trying to develop a
vision well you can start with that and
in the future authoring program we walk
people through a series of questions
because the real question is well how do
you want your life to proceed but that's
pretty generic and if you're
not accustomed to self-reflection you
haven't been socialized so that you're
self-reflective you don't even know
where to start you know people will say
well what what do you want to do with
your I don't know well that's not a very
good answer it means you're vague as
hell but it may be true so you can ask
yourself more specific
questions where's the value in your
friendships and how could you Foster
that you know and those are hard
questions like maybe you have friends
that aren't that good for you you know
it's highly probable you know and you
might think well you know they're my
longest term friend and I've I've been
went around with them forever and the
answer is well if they're aiming down
man and if if they're the sort of people
who will pull you down when you start to
move move up you are not doing them any
favors by allowing them to get away with
that so don't be thinking that you know
you can put up with someone indefinitely
just because you have had a long-term
relationship with them and that doesn't
mean you shouldn't be
loyal the question is loyalty to what if
you're facilitating misbehavior on the
part of someone you love that's not
loyalty right at some point loyal is
like [__] you I've had enough and you
better change because you're headed in a
bad Direction and I'm not going to be
around to watch it and that's love to
say that if it's true so what do you
want from your friends friends and what
can you give them like so the the real
question is it's like who's the right
person for me when you're thinking about
dating isn't the right question it's
like what can I offer to people is the
right question if you answered that
question you'd have no problem with
dating right okay so it's just backwards
but so how how how would you want your
friendships to be constituted your
relationships with family your mother
did a stellar job of this about 20 years
ago she decided she was going to clean
up her relationships with her sisters
her and her brother and her dad and she
did that first by taking a look at what
she was bringing to the table there was
trouble it's like you can't fix someone
else's trouble but you can certainly
figure out what you're doing that's
stupid and what she was primarily doing
that was causing her trouble was
insisting on her point of view and she
wanted to she was the youngest kid in
the family she had reason to want her
viewpoint to be appreciated but she just
let that go she didn't put her viewpoint
forward anymore and then her sisters
started to talk to her and tell her what
was going on and she listened and then
she got to know them and eventually she
got to say something now and then that
they would listen to you know and and
she straightened that right out so you
can do that with your family you have to
have a vision you know how would you
like your family Affairs to lay
themselves out and where do you want
your career to go and what do you how
are you going to educate yourself and
how are you going to take care of
yourself mentally and physically and you
have to ask yourself this question the
question is very
straightforward if you could have what
you
wanted what would it be well people
rarely ask themselves that question and
they bloody well rarely stick around for
the answer they also limit themselves oh
terribly it's amazing
it's amazing what you can do with a plan
and you could say what do I want and I'd
say shoot high oh yeah because it's
crazy once you put it on paper and you
think about it you start devote yourent
efforts to it yeah you start recognizing
opportunity that leads in that direction
so you might as well shoot high and see
what happens yeah well this idea there's
a kind of a new age idea of
manifesting but there's a there's a core
of Truth in it because the way your
perceptual systems are set up is that
once you spe ify a Target you
preferentially attend to the world in a
manner that makes the objects that exist
in accordance with that Target much more
Salient that's how you navigate you know
if you're going to walk from here to the
next yard what's going to stand out for
you are the things you have to walk
around right because otherwise you won't
get there well that's everything is like
that once you set a goal as soon as you
set a goal the world lays itself out for
you Pathways forward
facilitators and obstacles and
everything else that's irrelevant right
right that's how the perceptual and
emotional systems work so and then you
might say well how do they work if you
have no goal and the answer is well
they're thrown into chaos there's too
many choices there's no Direction you're
anxious you and you're confused well
that's not a good way of of propagating
yourself along the
pathway you know and with regards to the
difficulty of the goal there's rules for
that too if you a child you love you and
you give them a task you want to set
them up for Success which means they
have some probability of attaining the
goal compared to the effort
exerted the animal literature seems to
indicate for example that if you pair
animals together to play the loser
animal has to win a third of the time so
one of the things you could say is like
a high-end goal for you might be one
where you have a 65% chance of failure
right so you don't want it to be a
99.9% chance of failing I mean there
might circumstances well there might be
circumstances under which that really
high-end goal is worth achieving if the
payoff is massive and you can break it
up into sub ruls where the where the pro
probability of Victory is higher but you
want to play a fair game with yourself
and the game is see there's two games
going on at the same time one is can you
attain the goal but the other is can you
expand your adaptive competence while
you're attaining the goal and that's why
you don't want to just set a goal that
for sure you can hit yeah right cuz if
for sure you can hit it it doesn't
stretch you and the goal is to stretch
plus to climb and and you don't want to
set goals that I mean I said shoot high
but for instance like my goal with
exercise this year because I've got
really sick last year and I haven't been
exercising for a long time then I had a
pregnancy and my goal for exercising was
twice a week for 15 minutes each right
right and was like going from zero to
that that would be a huge step in the
right direction and then and then I have
like after that three times a week for
30 minutes each session so you don't
shoot high so you're not a rule there
too so imagine that you decide twice a
week for 15 minutes and then it's a
month and you didn't do it so you don't
say oh I'm an idiot and I'm a failure
and this will never work you say well
how about once a week for 15 minutes and
then if that doesn't work it's like how
about once week for 10 minutes like well
seriously there's a rule and the rule is
aim at the goal in case of failure
either discipline yourself because maybe
there's some things you can sort out or
scale the goal back somewhat until you
do it well this is a very this is
humility that's humility scale the goal
back till you do it that's humility
because that's actually taking yourself
into account as you are and that can be
bitter especially if you're trying to
develop in an area where you're weak
because you may have have to start very
low like exercise once a week for 10
minutes y yeah yeah yeah well I I dealt
with an old guy he was about 83 at one
point and he had a rough life man he had
fallen off a ladder and broke his neck
and he was permanently fused in a very
awkward and uncomfortable position right
and he was in chronic pain and he was
old and he couldn't do much and so he
kind of had it he was laying in bed
depressed out of his mind and he he
would have just if maid would have been
available he would have taken it in a
second like all depressed people by the
way so what was what we what did we do
for
him God I think we started
with I think I started with can you look
at a magazine for 30 seconds a and then
the next step was can you sit up in bed
but by two weeks we had him walking up
and down the hallway you know like his
life was never going to be
Stellar but the reason I'm using him as
an example is because I don't care
how impaired you are there's something
that you could do that is a slight
improvement over where you're at and you
might think oh my God it's so depressing
to consider that I have to start that
slow it's like fair enough but but this
is where another fact of life comes into
play progress tends not to be linear it
tends to be curval linear like this
almost exponential or geometric and so
you can start pretty damn minimally and
you'll speed up if you're consistent
you'll speed up pretty rapidly so you
don't have to worry about having to
start like a fool this is why Yung said
the fool is the precursor to the
Savior you have to allow yourself to be
the kind of idiot that you actually are
to begin with this is something you need
to know when you're imagine you're
trying to what would you say train your
partner to do the
dishes you know
regularly your goal might be they do the
dishes immediately after dinner seven
nights a week or maybe three because you
do it half the time whatever it happens
to be and they do a good job
well that's not necessarily where to
start once badly would be a start and
that's a huge start because once is way
more than zero yeah way more you know
and then you have to be patient and you
have to allow the person including
yourself to stumble forward stupidly a
lot so when I used to counsel my clients
for example to go out on dates with
their Partners they were both they'd
both just hate that idea and then they'd
go out and have a miserable time and
then they'd come back and trumpet
triumphantly the misery of their date so
that they never had to do that again and
it took took a lot of talking to walk
through like it's like if you're married
you're going to be let's say you're
married for 30 years and you could have
three dates a week you know three times
of intimacy and and close personal
relationship a week let's say it's three
that's not bad two to three is probably
about right so let's say three so it's a
100 years 3,000 over 30 years well if
you have to do that
stupidly 100 times as you're practicing
it's like it's only 100 over over 3,000
it's nothing it's a tiny fraction of the
total so you can stumble forward
stupidly and you need to allow your
partner that luxury you can teach them
slowly and you can reward progress as
well as
performance good thing to apply to
yourself so if you manage to exercise
you know once a week for 10 minutes like
you give yourself a little pad on the
you don't have to go overboard you're
not Queen of the Universe look at me
yeah yeah yeah yeah well that's that
could be a reasonable way of obtaining
social support for
it
yeah we'll see I think I can manage that
I hope I can manage that I could really
use some
exercise
um how should people manage
jealousy well one of the things you want
the first thing I think you probably
want to think through is um do you want
a partner that no one else
wants
definitely not well but you actually
have to think that through because the
answer could easily be yes like husbands
will punish their wives out of dressing
attractively they do that all the time
and then they're all [__] because
their wives she really let herself go
it's like well that's cuz you punished
her mercilessly every time she looked
like any man might take a second glance
at her you stupid bastard and you did
that because you're unconscious and
jealous and now you're resentful cuz
your wife listened to you it's a pretty
stupid strategy so you have to think
like do you want a partner that other
people would find attractive and and
there's a possibility that the answer to
that is no and the reason is is because
you're insecure and perhaps for valid
reasons about whether or not you're
actually much of a catch and so then
maybe you should do some sorting out
about that it's like well let's say you
think you're not much of a catch okay
there's two possible reasons for that
one is you're not much of a catch the
other is you're too hard on yourself and
it's probably going to be a little of
both like maybe you had a hypercritical
father for example and nothing you ever
did was good enough for something or
hyper hyper conservative what about
those
people I'll give you an example I'm
going to talk about this we'll see if
Jordan's okay with this when Jordan and
I first started dating or when I met him
I was wearing like short shorts and a
crop top because I figure I can only
wear a crop top for so long I'm going to
wear it now yeah um and he and then he
told me he wanted to marry me and then
we got married and everything and about
six months into the relationship he kind
of just like slightly neged all the like
outfits like that so eventually I had no
crop tops cuz I was like if you don't
want me to wear it I'm not going to wear
it I like wearing them I don't think
there's anything wrong with them yeah
but um they're gone and then about 6
months after that he goes where are your
crop dos yeah well where are all those
clothes I was like you they're gone
right anyway so he's reverted back well
I do think well I do think that that's
actually a place where husbands and
wives can negotiate you know like I like
buying Tammy clothes and we've I
actually like it quite a bit as it turns
out and we've had a lot of discussions
about what's appropriate what's sexy
when and where to come to a to uh
agreement about that now I would say
she's less flashy by temperament in her
mode of self- display than you are so
you know
Tammy is
more
understated probably because she's less
extroverted oh definitely then I'm not
understated yeah right right and so and
I'm not jealous so that's not being a
problem but I like like I'm perfectly
happy for her to be attractive now if I
was jealous well we we can go through
the reasons you're not much of a catch
you're too hard on yourself so you don't
think you're much of a catch the other
is your your wife is actually on the
prowl yeah yeah right well all has to be
sorted out and she can be on the prowl
kind of unconsciously you know and and
that's even hard to sort out because to
some
degree being a bit on the prowl is
playful right because you don't want to
go to a party where no one flirts at
all a good party even among people who
are married and happily married is
there's an there's an edge but it takes
a lot of sophistication to walk that
precise L right you have to be awake
it's a complicated game it's and it's
also a friendly Edge right people yes
and and it's a friendly Edge where
everyone is playing yeah and that only
works if you have trust in the
relationship that's right that's right
that's right well so there's you know if
you're jealous it means if you're
jealous there's a lot of ugly things in
your relationship and your psyche that
need to be sorted out that's the first
thing you can be sure of and it the
second thing you can be sure of is it's
going to be really convenient of you to
assume that it's your partner's fault
now having said that
hey you could start with the a prior
presumption that it's 50% your partner's
fault probably isn't because if you're
the jealous here's another question you
can ask yourself if you're
jealous have you been jealous in every
relationship and if the answer to that
is yes it's either well you're either
picking them pretty badly there sport
which is your problem anyways or you're
the problem yeah all women those women
they always make me jealous it's like no
sorry buddy that's you now that doesn't
mean you could have you could have also
been picking women who really don't care
much for you and who are sort of with
you maybe because you've enticed them
into feeling sorry for you and they
really are on the lookout for someone
else and no wonder like that could
easily be the situation yeah Jordan's
reverted yeah and so what was the what
was the what was the agreement I think I
just kind of like was like well if
that's what he wants that's fine it
didn't really bother me that much I was
just like I don't think that's necessary
like that was my opinion I don't think
that's necessary I'm not well like
saying I'm you know no to the crop tops
or no to like just certain outfits I was
like I don't think that's necessary
because I don't think I'm going over
board and I'm not looking for anybody so
I think that's not necessary but if that
makes you uncomfortable then okay that
was kind of my no but I think that's
right I think he's reverted so now you
also you also like assuming that your
husband is you know vaguely reasonable
you don't want to dress in a manner that
makes him uncomfortable now you have to
sort out whether that's reasonable like
with your mom if she asks me what I
think of something she's wearing I just
tell her now I really like her sense of
style and so the probability that I'm
going to be happy with what she's
wearing is quite high but it's not
always that the case and you could say
well I could have just always said it
was wonderful but while then that
compromises your word it also makes it
impossible for me to trust for her to
trust me in in my discussion of what
she's wearing and it's also see a man
will also tell a woman oh you look great
in everything honey and what he means by
that is he could mean a bit like I think
you're sexy so what difference does it
make but it could also mean well I don't
really want to pay any attention to your
damn clothes and so I wish you'd shut up
and if I give you a compliment maybe you
won't ask me to think anymore right and
that's not helpful because actually how
your partner dresses like it's not the
most important thing in life by any
stretch of the imagination but it's not
nothing and it also can be fun very fun
in fact so it's one of the things that
adds variation to your
relationship so that's why you can't
just think the whole Fashion World is
like pointless and shallow even though
it is pointless and shallow it's not you
know well there's an aspect of it if
it's raised to the highest place it
becomes pointless and shallow but in its
place it's like well why not you just
wear a sack also people treat you
completely differently depending on what
clothes you wear so you might as well
use that to your advantage depending on
what you want to get out of people it's
like what are you looking
for well this is especially true in
things like job interviews it's like
you're going to put your best foot
forward or not it's like learn how to
wear a suit you Dim wet well I don't
want to work for someone who judges me
on my appearance it's like well good
then be a slob and cover yourself with
Cheeto dust and live in the basement
where you don't see anyone and nurse
delusions of your moral superiority that
sounds like fun you could do that or buy
a suit you Dim wit you know it's like
really there's just no excuse for that
and there's a tremendous amount of
intellectual it's like the people who
say I don't have time for small talk
it's like well people aren't going to
Bear their hearts to you the first
second they meet you they're going to
tell you something trivial to see if
you're so stupid you can't even respond
to that and you know I don't have time
for Small Talk generally means I have no
social skills and so why of course
people aren't going to engage now it's a
little more complicated because people
high and openness want to move to a
discussion of ideas and so they're not
interested in just like local gossip you
know yeah so that's a complicating
Factor but that aside Small Talk has its
place it's like you got to check each
other out a bit before you talk about
anything where there's a consequence do
you think just going back to a different
area of a conversation do you think we
could make a course for Peterson Academy
that taught like specific to people that
taught introverts to be extroverted in
certain situations because you said you
had clients that you taught to be
extroverted oh definitely oh I bet that
would be really helpful for people and
agreeable people how to be disagreeable
we should do that in a course well
that's an idea could be incredibly
helpful well that would be something if
we did that in a course what we should
probably do is find someone who's
agreeable and wants to be more
disagreeable and them and film it and
edit it that's a way more effective way
of doing that so you think you could
train agreeableness to be more I know I
can because I did it lots look people
come to therapy for a variety of reasons
sometimes it's because they're in a life
situation that's very very complex and
they need to think their way through it
sometimes it's because they're suffering
from a surfite of negative emotion
anxiety or depression but the third most
common Rush rationale is for assertive
assertiveness training yeah it's not
assertiveness it's disagreeableness that
okay yeah well and basically what it is
in some ways it's negotiating strategy
yeah you know and what I taught a lot of
my clients a lot of my clients tripled
their income in two or three years
because we put together a plan and part
of that was how to position yourself so
you can be disagreeable to position
yourself to properly be disagreeable you
have to position yourself so that you
know when to say no and so that you do
and can say no so like if you're my boss
and I need something from you to
continue working happily for you which
should be my aim I have to
have I have to be confident enough when
I approach you to put forward my case
without fear well so that means at
minimum like if you came to me and said
well you want to work to get a raise
from your boss and you're afraid of it M
so now well it's a strategy it's okay
bring your CV next week let's take a
look well I don't want to it's full of
holes it's like yeah that's your life
full of holes your life is full of holes
so you have no Foundation to stand on so
you can't negotiate so bring your CV and
we'll go through it and we'll see what
holes are rectifiable maybe that'll take
a year or two
years right because you're afraid you
can't find another job as good as the
one you have you think it was a fluke
that you got this job because you're
kind of underqualified you don't know
how to advertise your skills you don't
even know how to make a case for
yourself so you're terrified of going to
talk to your boss well all that has to
be like straightened out that has to be
straight maybe you should be terrified
right well exactly now people are often
more terrified than they should be
because most
look bosses if they have any sense are
just as afraid of losing good employees
as the employee is of losing their job
and if your boss isn't afraid of losing
you and you're good it's time to find a
new boss right that's just ass sign
you're in a counterproductive place so
it's not like you the boss has all the
playing cards it's just not true like
and certainly that's definitely true oh
definitely and managers like people who
go to job interviews are terrified
generally but the people who are doing
the interviews are even more terrified
if they have any sense because they know
perfectly well that if they hire a dud
they're stuck with them like forever
especially in a mid-level corporation
and their life or in Canada or their
life can just be hell so you there's you
hold plent if you're a good employee you
hold plenty of cards and so what I would
do with my clients is first of all it's
like okay are you in a bargaining
position and that might be do you have
enough are you competent are you
demonstrably competent does your boss
know you're competent do you have the
confidence to go along with that and
have you advertised yourself in a manner
that's commensurate with your competence
well probably not so we sort all that
out and then it's like well then what do
you want want and more than that what
are you offering like if you go to
someone who's halfways reasonable and
you say
look um I'd like to be wholeheartedly
able to donate 25% more effort to my job
here's what I've done already and here
are the impediments you know I have to
have another job because I'm not making
enough and also when I work for you in
such and such way I don't get any credit
for it and this is demoralizing me and
so what I want is a 15% raise with the
possibility of a 25% raise 3 years down
the road and here's what I'm willing to
offer in return and this is why it's to
your
advantage well that's the case you want
it you don't go in there and think I you
say I think I deserve a raise it's like
everyone wants a raise
buddy that's not a strategy right right
so one of the things that when you teach
someone to be assertive to be say more
disagreeable is you're putting them in a
position to negotiate to say no and that
and what you want to have in your back
pocket with any discussion you have with
uh with a uh like a supervisor is your
final option is to say sayora man I've
got other options if you don't have
other options you're in no place to
negotiate for raise yeah if you have no
other options you're being paid as much
as you
deserve right exactly that's why you
settled for it to begin with so you want
to put yourself in a position where you
have options and
I've listened to you for so long that
this is how I negotiate with you yeah
good yeah good right right well that's
worked well look when we negotiated our
businesses both you and Julian did the
same thing the major negotiation you
went through first you know you were
very interested in Peterson Academy but
what I wanted to hear from you is okay
you're interested in Peterson Academy
all right so I want you to do like an
outstanding job okay well what's the
price
and so what I want to hear from you is
under what conditions are you willing to
do a stellar job and I don't want some
snow job I want to know and I want to
know it for decades it's like no no I
want you maximally motivated now if
you're demanding so much that it would
decrease my motivation well then I have
to tell you that it's like no I can't
offer you that because then if you had
pushed too hard all this is especially
true if you're dealing with people that
have options so let's say you got one
over me in the negotiation and it turned
out that it was 75% for you so to speak
and 25% for me well all that would
happen is I'd deprioritize that
endeavor like during that negotiation I
wanted you with both feet in right
absolutely given everything else you're
doing exactly and anytime you're
negotiating with someone who options you
have to think you don't be you're not
thinking how do I get the best possible
deal no or or you reconstrue what best
possible deal means if you're dealing
with someone who's competent best deal
is they'll pay attention mhm right so
you got to think of it from their
perspective if I was in their shoes so I
don't remember exactly what we
negotiated with Peterson Academy I think
you own the majority 55 right right so
that puts the decision making
responsibility on your shoulders now you
know a cynic would say well now you have
the power well that's stupid because if
you're using power well first of all
you're not going to get very far with me
because I'll just go do something else
but also the right way of thinking about
that is no no you have the
responsibility and that means I can go
off and do other things not that I'm not
attending but that I you know so and I
would rather that this was your baby
fundamentally like how is that not
useful to me well I want to micromanage
everything it's like well if I want to
micromanage everything why am I going to
partner with you yeah that's another
thing for people who are listening if
you're a micromanager you're you're
either bent in your perception of value
or you're dealing with the wrong people
yeah you to micromanage someone that's
the wrong
person yeah you want to be around people
you think oh you did a great you want to
think oh you did really if you're
fortunate you think oh you did a way
better job on that than I would have
then you know you got the right person
man and then of course jealousy can
arise it's like well that person's so
competent it's like this is one of the
things I loved about working with Bob
Peele my grad
supervisor Bob was had his feet firmly
enough on the ground and he was a very
competent person he's sort of
multi-dimensionally competent you know
there was a lot of things that Bob was
good at he was very balanced person and
he had
zero Envy of his students if he had a
student who was shining in some
particular way it was like that was just
fine with Bob good yeah yeah was need to
take great credit for what other people
do that's it just means you're not doing
your own thing enough that's all it
means there's plenty for everyone to do
plenty and if you don't think there is
you have a malthusian view of the world
zero some there's only so much if I get
70% you can only have 30 it's like no I
think that can also come from working
with a lot of incompetent people though
and then you're like okay well I only
want to give away 5% because I'm going
to do anything anyway everything anyway
right so that might just not be
partnering with the right people well
that's part of it that that and that may
be part of being too agreeable as well
right because you just say yes to I I
gave him a chance don't give people
chances
you know and I'm not saying that like
the son of a [__] who never gives
anyone a chance it's like if you're
trying to hire someone giving someone a
chance is a very bad reason it's not
helpful it's not helpful to them it's
not it's not helpful to anyone it might
make you feel good about yourself
morally for 15 minutes it's a very bad
strategy yeah you know now that doesn't
mean that with careful analysis you
couldn't take a risk on someone young
and inexperienced but you would have had
to evaluate them very carefully to see
if the risk was well that's what
happened with you when you started
working with me like you know I knew you
didn't know enough to do what you were
doing but I figured I didn't know
anything that first year was intense I
didn't know anything about anything you
remember having conversations with your
agent not knowing what a green room was
send over his rider was like you're
going to have sorry Justin you're going
to have to explain that too I was like
I'm going to be asking for a lot of
words for the next for the next
well when you start when you start
something new well when you start
something new you don't know anything
what you did start with as far as I was
concerned is I figured that
you could learn it and that you
would and you did thank you well good
work it's been fun it's been some ups
and downs but it's definitely been fun
yeah well it's it's there's no shortage
of challenge in what we're doing and
that's
good yeah yeah no you've done real well
and I'm very curious that's the other
thing that that that the allegation
especially to your kids is useful for
it's like I'm curious it's like okay
here's an opportunity I've always been
curious about this with people I you
know in my lab I handed out
opportunities to people all the time
it's like oh you think you have a clue
do you here go see what you can do with
this you know and sometimes people come
back they just knock it out of the park
it's like here's another one for you and
then other times people come back and
say Here's seven reasons I couldn't do
it it's like yeah okay that's just they
had seven reasons too not always you
know sometimes you have to have some
sense you know if everybody's if the if
all their family members got killed in a
car accident you know you could probably
take that into
consideration that's kind of that's kind
of how I felt with Jordan when we
started working with him which was which
which which Jordan my my husband H
Jordan but it was like I'd give him I
was like I need help I'm over like I'm
doing way too many things at the same
time I could use somebody I communicate
with all the time cuz either way either
way I needed to work with somebody
closely to help manage the companies and
so I was like that might as well be my
husband otherwise I'm going to be in
constant communication with somebody
else so that's not ideal and so that's
kind of how I felt with him which was
like well here's a bunch of stuff what
happens and then it's been great
obviously well c yeah it's expanded my
capacity yeah well I would say something
very similar has happened with I mean
Tammy and I always
cooperated especially around the
kids well and that was our Prim well I
would say that that was probably
perfectly suitable because the period of
time I'm talking about was the period of
time that was primarily occupied by kids
then afterwards you know everything blew
up around me and she decided she was
going to get on board
and she's just expanded her confidence
massively as consequence it's been great
because it wasn't obvious to us yeah
what we would do once our kids left
that's the problem that everybody faces
that's been taken care of nicely that's
definitely taken care of what if we
don't have much to do better make we
weren't worried about that exactly but
we were uncertain about what would be
the mutual focal point of our life right
because kids unite you it's a joint
project and so a lot of
marriages run into difficulty once the
kids leave because the joint project has
evaporated and then what do you
do well we don't have that problem at
you certainly do not have that problem
no well thank you Dad for coming on my
podcast good luck with the oh we might
as well just say for everybody he's
going on tour again tickets are still
available Jordan B Peterson . 51 cities
across the United States I'm going to
do what I did in the Genesis lectures in
The Exodus seminar except more broadly
I'm going to walk through the stories
that organize our imagination that's the
right way of thinking about it right a
culture is a shared Corpus of
stories and the stories are the
foundation and we have foundational
stories in the west and those are
stories derived from the judeo-christian
tradition for better or worse and I'm
going to explain why that's the case and
how that's for better not for worse
because they're very profound stories
and you can tell that not least because
we have the cultures upon
which the cultures that are predicated
upon those stories are highly
functional that's a
hint it's a hint it's not proof it's a
hint or at least it's an indication that
other forms of organization are to be
regarded with extreme skepticism mhm
like communism for example or
fascism well good luck with that tour
that should be fun and then Peterson
Academy is launching late February your
book is going to be released November
that's the plan and then maybe we'll get
started on this dating app with all our
free
time sounds like fun yep yep yeah and
there's all sorts of sub projects nested
in there yep so okay well thanks again
nice seeing you nice seeing you over
Christmas and everything it's been fun
it's been real good yeah and
congratulations on your baby thank you
yeah and your
husband thank you
[Music]
yeah